foreign
Lotus 2 has way more sex I've asked to
come and watch some of it
I mean they said it's a closed set but I
was able to get in
[Music]
describe you to
YouTube
well Tanya I think she means well I
think she wants to be loved yeah and you
want that with Greg with anybody yes
without anyone not not just Greg hey
where are you going oh don't you want me
to wash up first it's hot out
I got swamp crotch
[Music]
always thinking of me
our characters are very similar actually
we both are very self-involved in our
own kind of pity and problems and we
aren't self-aware of how we kind of fit
into the big picture of life I think I'm
much more self-aware than you you think
Tanya's self-aware
well I mean I think when you're older
you can be a narcissist but still know
your incredible limitations and I think
when you're young you don't even know
they exist I completely agree with that
I think that Porsha thinks that she's
not the problem but here she is in
Sicily and she's just been told to get
lost and basically not be an assistant
anymore but she takes it like the end of
the world I didn't tell you to stop
being an assistant I still want you to
do everything I need all of your help
I'm not dismissing you at all how much
you stay stay close because I might need
you but just lay low and not come out of
your room okay
that's the thing too about Tanya's
version of like help and the things she
needs an assistant or I think in the
first episode is the only time you
really see Porsha kind of being an
assistant like she comes into the resort
like holding you know bags and telling
the bellmen where to put things but
then when you tell me to go to my room
I'm still kind of on call for you but
it's really just a lot of sitting in the
other room while you're crying or like
standing there well I hope by the next
few episodes you evolved
yeah you think there's hope I I
certainly hope so because I your lack of
appreciation
for for anything that's true I'm very
entitled yeah
[Music]
I think I would rather actually go alone
than with any of the characters other
than Luchia she's very beautiful I mean
she actually makes most people's trip
better
welcome to the world's largest is
[Music]
I always show up with like eight
suitcases when I go on a trip and then
when you open up the luggage it has
nothing that I could possibly wear
nothing that's right for the trip I show
up and I have all these stupid things
that I don't need in my hotel room I
don't I don't know why well also it's
been freezing here and we thought you
know like Sicily in the spring and
summer it's gonna be so hot but we got
here and it's been freezing cold and
everyone's bought puffer jackets
[Music]
I love the desert like a deserty
mountain to hike I don't know if that's
the most popular opinion for vacation
but I feel most at home in the desert I
want to always go where there's
everything is ancient you know I want to
stay in some
really old castle when someone says like
oh my God Jennifer we're gonna go to
this place I you know we're renting this
house and look at we found it on a
really cool website we're like this and
I'm like is it old because if it's not
old and crumbling and cool I have no
interest
[Music]